oui moi d'abord heureuse d'être arrivée
en tête des 12 listes candidates dans
nord donc c'est une victoire
il faut le souligner après un petit
tristesse pour notre troisième isabelle
kharkov car nous ratons le troisième
siège à quatre voies quatre-voies quand
vous savez combien il en faut pour faire
un sénateur
autant dire que enfin voilà on est très
heureux de notre score et on a une
petite pensée pour isabelle voilà un mot
sur les centristes au sénat
votre groupe pourrait constituer une
force avec cinquante sénateurs c'est ce
qu'on entendait en plateau à l'instant à
une réaction à ce chiffre
mais écoutez on l'espérait nous savions
que cette élection sénatoriale ne
ressemblerait pas à l'élection
législative que la séquence des annonces
de l'été a été dure pour les élus locaux
et que je pense qu'ils ont pris
conscience qu'il fallait un contrepoids
et que le sénat joue ce rôle et assume
ce cette nécessaire démocratie
parlementaire que nous devons avoir
porte à porter la voix des territoires
alors qu'à l'autre kalou être maintenant
la ligne de ce groupe union centriste
quel est votre avis sur cette question
notamment par rapport à emmanuel macron
et par rapport voilà à cette
construction et bien d'un grand d'une
grande coalition peut-être qu'ils
seraient favorables au président la
république
alors où est ce que je pense à titre
personnel c'est que d'abord on se
retrouve dans deux jours au groupe union
centriste udi que nous auront largement
l'occasion d'en débattre entre élus
centristes et que pour ma part mon
sentiment aujourd'hui c'est que les
centristes doivent être indépendants ils
doivent être exigeants et ils doivent
être force de proposition pour moi nous
devons garder une forte indépendance par
rapport à la majorité présidentielle
ça veut pas dire être contre
systématiquement ça veut dire qu'il faut
garder cette liberté de parole attendu
par le terrain la nécessaire expression
de l'assemblée sénatoriale pour porter
les propositions qui viendront mettre en
adéquation avec les besoins et les
attentes du territoire des réformes
nécessaires je pense qu'on ne doit pas
être dans l'opposition systématique
c'est une évidence
il faut que la réforme de notre pays
réussissent mais il faut aussi que le
gouvernement entente entendre qu'il doit
construire avec tous il nous a construit
en prenant le pouls du terrain en
prenant le pouls des collectivités et en
exceptant certaine inflexion
voilà ce que je pense et le centre me
paraît être totalement dans cette ligne
et est fabriquée pour ça on a toujours
été force de proposition il faut l'être
plus que jamais en gardant notre
indépendance